here's my tips on five easy ways to help
overcome writer's blog writer's block is
you know is something that's daunting to
a lot of writers especially screen
letters that are trying to finish their
scripts it's really our antagonist so
here's some hints that I have for you
guys tip number one change your
environment you know as writers we
Cooper cells up in these dark rooms or
we're stirring at that blinking cursor
on the blank page and we haven't even
typed the word well change where you
want or change what's around you to not
only inspire you but also to help clear
your mind right now I'm outside it's
beautiful it's quiet it's peaceful maybe
it's the beach you can go to Starbucks
or maybe a location where the movie
takes place so you can literally and
metaphorically envision your scene and
just right away tip number two is listen
to music music is a very therapeutical
thing especially encompass of writing i
would recommend soundtrack music as
opposed to lyrical music that can be
kind of distracting in a way but still
it's optional listening to music that
maybe fits the mood of the scene really
helps if you're in a jam and eat the
right your way out of scene so
soundtrack make the music is very very
helpful to me so I do that all the time
I listen to music a lot of times if I
need inspiration tip number three is
technology can be your best friend or
worst enemy so you want sometimes if you
can't get past that writer's block get
rid of the technology and use a pen and
paper pen and paper is most natural way
writing we've been doing it for
thousands of years so being able to have
your thoughts flow through to your
fingertips onto the pen and onto the
page really helps for me not it's not
for everybody but I really recommended
so I drilling right like that because
when you're typing if you think about it
you're subconsciously thinking about
what words you're trying to say on the
page as well as what's going on in the
scene so it's not
always the best way to write if you're
struggling with that writer's block so
pen and paper really helps for me if you
accompany that with music and being on
the beach then you're set up for a trio
of solutions for you for redress lock
tip number four is schedules and
deadlines so you want to make sure that
regardless to help as you are whether
you have one job two or three jobs
worthy of a family or your state home
mom maybe you want to schedule yourself
on a daily basis 10 to 15 minutes at
most maybe a half hour don't try to do
an hour to writing that's exhausting not
many writers write for several hours on
time so you have to kind of schedule
yourself into that whether it's on your
lunch break sometimes when i get home i
will write for about a half hour after
work as a way to decompress after a long
day's work so that's very helpful and
deadlines to is long term right mark on
the calendar like where you want to
finish the script because writing a spec
script is difficult on its own but if
you're running something in new ways
that we're going to see it's hard to
lose motivation so go ahead and set a
deadline on the calendar so that way you
can basically have a reason finish or
you can write for a screenplay
competition that's always really good
motivation to to get your work out there
and tip number five is set yourself up
for small goals now writing a 90 page
script or a feature script is very
daunting a lot of writers get stuck in
the second act or they're trying to
think how do I get to the next turning
point you know we know how the movie
begins we know how it ends but where's
that middle part so really right only a
few pages a day and focus on the overall
story as far as character arc for us
where the plots going but more
importantly minimize that focus to the
scene what's the characters in the scene
what do they want what are the obstacles
of protagonist is facing and so just
work at it seemed by scene line by line
and don't say how do I get to that too
or how do I get out to think about
houses character going to get out of
this situation so focus scene by scene
line by line and it makes you less
worried about the bigger picture so
those are my five easy tips on how to
overcome writer's block